pre-orders are doing you more harm than
good so it's time to stop paying for
games before you know enough about them
let's talk about it
tomorrow
fashion
gaming Trends are cyclical oh yeah and
this week we're talking about pre-orders
pre-orders why are we doing this why I
mean I feel like it's a slightly but
also not a slight leap if you know what
I'm saying we're talking about it
because one it's a perennially relevant
like talking point and often a hot bone
issue but right now we've had a couple
of things happen that although not
directly in A to B it sparked a
conversation between us and we thought
hey this is something that we could talk
about first thing that happened was
Diablo 4's microtransactions were
revealed and the prices are beefy let's
say yeah what was it like 20 30 for it I
mean they're all Cosmetics so I mean
yeah yeah none of that pay to win stuff
yeah uh God remember the auction house
oh I'll rest in peace
yeah the other thing is Street Fighter 6
on the eve of its launch was is getting
or has been updated to get de novo it's
anti-tamper an anti-cheat software and
it has been controversial in the past
because it's also had like an impact on
performance of games and also it's done
a bunch of wacky things to games so the
response to it is almost like um
knee-jerk when you see de novo appearing
you're like oh it's about to be
awful so those two things happen and
generally the kind of like what ties
them together is the community response
is this was unexpected Gamers and games
they take pre-ordering games for just as
a normal day-to-day thing but we're in a
situation where we're doing that not
knowing the complete story around games
because if you think about it in both
these scenarios the marketing leading up
to their release never really mentioned
either of those two things pre-orders
have been tied to video games for a very
long time back in the day you had to get
your pre-order in either to make sure
that the shop was going to have enough
copies gauge interest that way or if
like me you had a special shop that
would post games out early first of all
let's do the usual like if you're super
into pre-ordering firstly who are you
secondly fair play we don't want to
yucky um do whatever you want this is
just like an art perspective on it I
think the important thing to kind of
distinguish is pre-orders have changed
in a lot of ways I remember back in the
day like at least PS2 era
um that was like the last time I
pre-ordered a game and I learned my
lesson because look at me after
pre-ordered a game it's what he is look
me I'm smart
I mean like I was burned hard because
that game was a PS2 copy of Devil May
Cry 2 which was absolutely brutal for me
um I used to pre-order all the time like
the 360 PS3 years in the PS2 era and
even like bleeding into some of of the
360 PS3 error the pre-orders you were
doing were retailer side right like at
least for my experiences in in London in
England UK
um it was you go to like game or HMV and
you'd be like they would do the usual
you better pre-order this because it's
not going to be in stock and you'd pay
like five pounds but that would be
subtracted from the cost of the full
game right yeah as someone who also
worked in retail and was in a game store
the dark years yeah the dark years when
they were like they might not have many
of these that's like they the
next day they would be like just boxes
and boxes of it the only situation where
saying like we might not have a lot of
these and it actually happened was
Nintendo game I was gonna say the Wii
yeah the Wii stuff was the Wii was
difficult to get we fit was difficult
metric Prime Trilogy was one that was
like when that came in and we were like
told to say like it might not be a lot
of them I was like I'm actually going to
say this because there's probably not
going to be a lot also I bought three of
them then in the era that we're talking
about the 360 PS3 error that's when the
Publishers and like marketing cottoned
onto it and started to make it a part of
the process right well that's when it
got built yeah Mass Effect 2 certainly
Arkham City every single retailer had a
different pre-order bonus Arkham cities
were particularly egregious yeah there's
that legendary Watchdogs chart where
it's like all the editions and pre-order
bonuses and you had to like
cross-reference it which whichever one
you know that was PS4 right yeah because
I mean in the PS4 years you also had
like augment your pre-order and yeah
Deus Ex evolve
um there's the massive I think the 360
error PS3 error Mass Effect had all
those costumes that were like one was at
Walmart one was that wasn't one like Dr
Pepper since then like I think
pre-orders have changed a little bit
this they were still very much like
publisher and mocking initiatives
um and now retailers also benefit from
it to a degree there's like a quid pro
call between games companies and
retailers now I'm even more focused on
pre-order bonuses or early access to
some aspect of the game well pre-orders
had to change because you know
historically you know it was the the
false scarcity of making sure your your
store had a copy but a physical copy but
now with digital downloads
there is uh less of a need for that
there's obviously going to be some
people that don't have a good internet
connection they can't download these
hundred
games here a hundred gig games and if
you think about it every kind of reason
that we're told to pre-order or
encourage the pre-order is kind of
and I think of them as like at
best they're kind of rubbish at worst
they're like anti-consumer it's like if
a debut trailer or a like a gameplay
video comes out for any game it usually
ends with pre-order now and that is
basically monetizing your interest and
your hype around the game right and we
see something it looks cool and you
think I'm interested and then we've been
trained to express that interest by
putting money down so a lot of if we're
being honest a lot of us Define
ourselves by our interests right you're
literally wearing a Demolition Man shirt
and a metal gear jacket listen I like
Simon Phoenix and snake so to a degree
like we almost have this conditioning to
pre-order stuff because if we feel like
it's important to us let's pay the money
to it but like the business and like the
transactional reasons are like more
obvious right games are expensive as
hell to make so yeah obviously we're
coming at it from the pre-ordering is
maybe not good all the time but there
are legitimate business cases for it uh
video games especially in the last 20
years have become
just yeah
um and you know obviously you don't want
to think that we're calling out just the
Triple A here it's very important for
Indies to put a lot of bonuses like the
knickknacks you get almost never worth
it like very are you saying that six of
gollums best phrases and poses by the
way I have that game and I have that
Edition he has one phrase that he says
which is my precious and I actually
think there are only four emotes really
yeah uh or maybe five all of them
involve him chasing a flying chasing a
fly Resident Evil 4 remake for example
there's an attache case that will
increase the drop rate of gunpowder so
you can make ammo there are people out
there who would genuinely benefit from
having that and it's a good gameplay
consideration for people who might not
be as skilled or or you know might not
want to feel the constant grind of
almost being out of ammo the fact that
they created that means that Capcom saw
a use for it
but then they did the thing of
making you pay for it which is extremely
I think like anti-consumer usually that
just gets added to the game for you
to buy or it's for free like running
game of the year yeah or the mass effect
costumes eventually were just in the
game right like yes you could just buy
that stuff
um on the Cerberus Network and then the
other thing is the betas I think this is
the worst part of it like getting paying
money to get access to a beta is crazy
you are paying someone to do testing for
them or provide some sort of telemetry
for them right they're taking data away
from you playing the game and using it
to change the game or like help them
understand where their game is at but
that is something that a tester gets
paid for or should be getting paid for
but in this scenario you're paying them
to play the game that isn't out so then
you can give them data to help them make
the game that's crazy that's wild in
these scenarios where I've pre-ordered
and like I'm suddenly learning denovos
in streets five six
How likely is it that you're gonna go
back and cancel that pre-order and How
likely is it that that process is easy
right now games are
too unpredictable in how they'll launch
when they'll launch and what the state
of them will be in launch at launch and
whether they're going to be feature
complete at launch to for us to be
happily paying money up front before we
know the full story and obviously as
someone who does reviews I'm going to
evangelize the fact that you should pay
attention to reviewers like the
pre-order system also kind of allows
developers and Publishers to sidestep
like critiques and Analysis in a big way
like we naturally have a confirmation
bias especially when you put money down
for something if I pay money for
something I don't want to then contend
with the fact that I made a mistake
because this thing is so Tam what can we
do the most important thing I would say
of all this in terms of like purpose is
you I hope you would agree I think your
degree is messaging the data and
providing insight into how popular or
how much interest there is going to be
around the game right wishlist wish
listed I love a wish list yeah wish
listing reminds me especially um
because there are so many indie games
that I'm always interested in yeah and
Indie developers have been very open
with like when they're like when you see
our indie game and you think that you're
interested in it wishlist it on Steam
core part Play Station they're on
Playstation their own Xbox we check to
make sure and they are available I think
the Xbox One is only available either on
Console or on browser you can't do it
through the app mainly yeah you can do a
PlayStation on the app
um but like that's a very easy way to
get the most important aspect or the
most important use out of
pre-ordering or pre-signaling your
interest right if you're interested in a
game
about it that's another metric to to
show interest and like I don't know
Watch trailers posting about it tweeting
about it whatever it's as valuable a
metric of Interest as pretty much
anything else out there and it's not
called Hard Cash yeah it's not called
Hard Cash and that's the thing situation
that we want to avoid we want to avoid a
situation where you're committed to
something before you really know the
full story around it and that is why I
think we should stop
pre-ordering or at least really think
about if you should be pre-ordering this
game and why you're pre-ordering it
because if it's just I like it and I
hope that it's good it's probably you
could probably just wait you know and
not do that and if it's because oh I
want to show my interest in it you've
got plenty of options to do it without
spending money
thanks again for watching everyone let
us know your thoughts on pre-ordering
games in the comments below like I
mentioned last week but now the event is
upon us dream hack Dallas is happening
this week and there's a whole lot of fun
things going on including fighting games
voice actors uh d d cosplay games
cosplay and so much more to bring the
gaming Community to life use code dream
big to save 20 if you're interested in
going yeah we're going to be cold
streaming it and uh if you want to get a
discount if you're going there you have
it there you have it uh you can find me
on Twitter at least James games I'm at
and we'll see you next time
no we need like
some kind of okay hanger